un rendez vous à noter sur votre agenda
les 80 mille mètres carrés des jardins
de villandry vont de nouveau être
accessible aux visiteurs dès le 1er
avril prochain
une première depuis la fin octobre et
les préparatifs vont bon train des
milliers de plants reste à mettre en
terre dans ce célèbre potager d'ornement
ainsi que dans les jardins en terrasse
dans les jours à venir le spectacle des
floraisons promet d'être spectaculaire
semelle coll vous avez des narcisses ici
là son nom elle elle émerge tout juste
les fritillaires il ya aussi des pensées
pas le temps d'attendre pour le
printemps à quelques jours de l'arrivée
des premiers visiteurs la course est
déjà lancée entre les légumes et les
fleurs du potager d'ornement ses cent
mille plants mis en terre chaque année
ici voilà tous les plants de choux et de
différents légumes qui est vendre
bientôt être mis en place il ya aussi
des salades répartis sur huit hectares
et quatre terrasses un festival de
couleurs sur le point d'éclore à côté de
la jardin de l'eau celui de l'amour et
le soleil au dernier niveau
les jardiniers sont 7 en ce moment
bientôt rejoint par trois autres pour la
saison et tout est prêt c'est ça ce
qu'on veut c'est montrer notre jardin
aux visiteurs sinon ça manque de sens et
retrouver ça à faire durant la floraison
des tulipes est imminente
la promesse pour les trois prochaines
semaines un nouveau spectacle tous les
jours pour l'accueil évidemment
villandry s'adapte l'intérieur du
château reste fermé et le port du masque
est obligatoire dans les jardins les
visiteurs ne se croiseront pas l'entrée
à ceux ci seront sans différencier on
l'a aussi un parcours suggéré dans les
jardins qui commence par les terrasses
de façon à éviter trop de croisement des
visiteurs principalement tourangeau pour
débuter la saison
mais les réservations internationales
ont déjà commencé avec des américains et
des anglais attendue cet été